Ich bin schon eine halbe Stunde auf oder so als ich bin jetzt nicht komplett noch im
Tiefschlaf.
Gucken wir mal ob Twitch schon gecheckt hat, dass der Stream am Start ist.
Nö.
Keil.
Also der Stream ist on, aber es gibt noch keine Benachrichtigung oder sonst irgendwas.
Ah yes.
Da müssen wir noch kurz warten.
Leute ich hab mir was Neues für den Stream überlegt und zwar sehr oftmals das Problem
wenn ich irgendwas bastel oder so, dass man das nur theoretisch sieht.
Also man sieht was ich bastel, man sieht vielleicht mein Foto von, aber man sieht nie wenn was
passiert.
So und ich hab jetzt, ich hab mir zum ausprobieren fünf Kameras bestellt, also eigentlich zur
Überwachung vom Eingangstor, weil die andere verreckt ist und zum ausprobieren und ich
hab noch eine übrig jetzt, die eigentlich ganz gut ist und zwar ich hab mir noch so
eine Kamera hier übrig.
Ähm, wie heißt das Ding, R500, irgendwie so, so ein Teil hab ich noch über, wie gesagt
ich hab fünf Stück bei Amazon bestellt unterschiedlicher mal auszuprobieren.
Die Schiena, übrigens hier diese Schiena Cam hat mich mega gebaited.
Ich hab billige Kameras, also ich hab Kameras bestellt von 30 bis so 90 Euro, weil ich ausprobieren
wollte was geht.
Und diese Kamera, die hab ich irgendwie für paar 30 Euro noch gekriegt, die hat mich
mega gebaited.
Ich hab gedacht komm wir probieren mal so eine billige, so eine billige Schiena Cam aus,
ob die tut.
Ich mein die soll nix anderes machen als mein Hoftor aufnehmen.
So, und jetzt das geile ist, ich hab das angeschlossen und eigentlich die schreiben offiziell, die
schreiben offiziell sie haben ein Web Interface, oh die schreiben offiziell sie haben ein Web
Interface.
So und ich mach ja Schiena Cams, ich mach ja Schiena Cams nie bei mir ins Netzwerk.
Also was hab ich gemacht, mein Raspberry Pi genommen, WLAN drauf eingerichtet und am
Netzwerk port vom Raspberry Pi die Kamera dran angeschlossen.
So und ich hab DHCP, DHCP Server laufen gelassen auf dem Raspberry Pi am Netzwerk port, so
hab ich angeschlossen, die Kamera, Kamera meldet sich an, zieht sich eine IP, mach ich den NMAP
Scan drauf und ist auch alles offen, RTSP, sonst was und dann geh ich mit dem Browser
auf die IP die sich die Kamera gezogen hat und es kommt Permission Denied, nee was verbinden
ist 403, 403.
Hä was ist das, so und dann bin ich rausgekommen, übrigens die Musik ist zu laut, so und dann
bin ich draufgekommen, die haben mich gebadet, das hier hinten, das hier hinten, diese mit
Alexa und hier diese Anzeige bedeutet, das ist eine Cloud Only Kamera, die hat nichts,
die geht nur über die offizielle App, das ist so ein Gebate, diese Shiela Camps, schicke
ich halt zurück, schicke ich halt zurück, aber es ist Cloud Only und was die gemacht
haben ist folgendes, die haben nicht etwa eine andere Kamera gebaut, nein die haben die
gleiche Kamera, einmal mit allen Funktionen und einmal mit allen Funktionen aber abgeschaltet
gebaut, weil sonst wäre da auf Port 80 kein Web Server, der Permission Denied macht und
ich habe mich im Internet schon mal schlau gemacht, ob man das irgendwie routen kann oder
ob man da irgendwie auf eine Kommando Zeile drauf kommt, aber bis jetzt habe ich nichts
gefunden, also kauft euch nicht diesen Shiela Crap, dafür sind 50 Euro oder 35 oder so wofür
ich es gekriegt habe, viel zu viel, weil die rein, rein Cloud ausgelegt sind, egal was
da sonst wo die im Internet schreiben, im Internet schreiben sie, sie haben Web Interface, sie
haben alles mögliche, RTSP Port ist offen aber hier habe ich kein Passwort zu, das geht
nur über die App, muss mal gucken ob es irgendwelche Software darauf gibt, die Sicherheitslücken
hat, die man vielleicht ausnutzen kann, aber ansonsten ist Gebate extrem hier, voll die
Verarschung, warum das übrigens so viele gute Bewertungen hat kann ich nicht verstehen,
die Leute die wollen wahrscheinlich ihre App verwenden und die wollen wahrscheinlich auch
in der China Cloud den ganzen Kram speichern, so und ich habe mir ja zwei Stück von denen
gekauft, das sind auch Chinesen, nachher SGDQ, echt geht nachher los, ich gucke ich aber
nicht mehr, doch ab und zu, aber ich gucke es nicht mehr so gern, ich gucke SGDQ nicht
mehr so gern, seit die so extrem über korrekt geworden sind, da darfst du teilweise gar
kein, also ich kann mich noch an den Run erinnern, wo irgendwie einer Owen Wilson Witze gemacht
hat oder wo sie sich irgendwie lustig gemacht haben über irgendeine Airline und danach
hat sich SGDQ entschuldigt bei der Airline und die Airline hat so gefragt, alter wer
seid ihr, was wollt ihr von uns, die sind so extrem, die sind so der Inbegriff von über
korrekt mittlerweile SGDQ, das finde ich ist irgendwie auch hinderlich für das Event,
dass da nicht mal einer irgendeinen doofen Spruch machen kann, aber klar ich meine die
sind ultra family friendly, gemeinnützig und sonst was, da musste das wahrscheinlich sein
und spätestens seit der bei SGDQ seit der Chat Closed ist und du sagen musst für den
Chat habe ich keinen Bock mehr drauf, da gucke ich mir lieber die ESA Events an, so zumindest
weil ich sagen wollte, was für den Stream ganz gut ist, die habe ich jetzt noch übrig
und ich habe mir gedacht was wir machen könnten, ich könnte die nehmen als Kamera mit der ich
Zeug im Stream zeige an was ich gerade rumbastle, zum Beispiel ich wollte dieses ESP32 Board
demnächst mal im Stream ausprobieren, hier das da, das hat ein Farbdisplay und die Sache
ist halt wenn ich da dran rumbastle man sieht nichts und da könnte ich einfach die Kamera
nehmen, irgendwo hin machen, beispielsweise irgendwo ins Schlafzimmer oder so, keine Ahnung
oder hier hinten irgendwo in die Ecke, ein bisschen ranzoomen, Stream anmachen hier im
OBS, dass man zumindest sieht wenn was passiert oder auch wenn wir uns irgendwelche Hardware
angucken oder sowas, dass man einfach sieht was passiert, das ist wahrscheinlich gar
nicht so schlecht und deswegen mache ich es in anderen Raum, dass ich nicht aus dem Bild
schaue. YpsilonX sagt ich bin sehr zufrieden, ich mache mal den Chatlog an, ich bin sehr
zufrieden mit Reolink, meine Firework läuft einfach den ganzen, ich habe gar nichts großartig
zur China Cloud gesehen ehrlich gesagt, man kann ja ausschalten, dass das Ding China Cloud
Access, also dass man P2P China Cloud Remote Access machen kann, aber es ist eh egal, weil
die Kamera ist bei mir eh in einem eigenen Netzwerk drinne, in einem eigenen WLAN drinne,
was erstens Client Isolation anhat, also sprich die WLAN Clients sehen sich untereinander
nicht und es kommen auch nicht ins Internet. Das einzige was in diesem China WLAN erlaubt
ist, ist NTNP und DNS Traffic, nee DNS Traffic noch nicht mal, nur NTP, nur NTP Traffic zu
meinem Router zum Zeitabrufen, das ist das einzige, der Rest ist nicht erlaubt, also aus
dem Netzwerk raus, insofern ja bei mir wird auch alles geblockt. Tja, wo wir gerade beim
Thema Blocken und Security Geschichten sind, ich habe hier ein Video gefunden, mal gucken
ob das was taugt, 5 Hardvermüten, die einfach gelogen sind, das erinnert mich ein bisschen
an so eine Serie, die ich mal bei mir auf YouTube hatte, die sich eigentlich nante,
aber ich bin nicht der Einzige, der sowas macht, warum nimmst du keine Access Kameras,
weil die fucking teuer sind und ich hier immer so ein bisschen ein bisschen mäßig auf Preis
Leistung gucke. So, das habe ich mal auf YouTube gemacht und mal gucken was, ich sag nicht
dass das irgendwie an meinem Zoll, weil so Videos können ewig alle machen, ja, also
doch Access Kameras sind ziemlich teuer, vor allem wenn man, what the fuck was, eben hat
meine Maus, was war denn das, irgendeine Windows Geschichte, ah mein, äh, Maus Without Borders
ist abgeschissen, ok wunderbar, ich kann grad nicht auf den zweiten Streaming Rechner zugreifen,
ok ich glaube das ist verreckt, ich glaube das ist kaputt, ja, das ist aber doof, ok
dann, dann killen wir das mal kurz, äh, Maus, wo ist es, hallo, what the fuck, hallo, was
ist denn jetzt schon wieder, hallo, Windows, Windows mach was, ah, das ist jetzt weg, Existinal,
ok, ich darf meine eigenen Sachen nicht beenden, ok, wie startet man, wie startet man ein Admin,
wie startet man einen Admin, einen Admin Taskmanager, wie geht das, wie startet man einen Admin Taskmanager,
kann man das nicht irgendwie sagen, erst Admin oder so, sudo, ha ha, oben in den Einstellungen,
wie, wo, wo, wo, ok, Task, Taskmanager, ah, excellent Chat, excellent, da seht ihr immer
und mich fragen die Leute, ob ich ihnen bei Computerprobleme helfen kann, was hätte ich
da irgendein Plan von, wenn das zu euch, ok, Endtask, bam, rip, so und jetzt muss ich erst
mal wieder starten, weil ansonsten kann ich ja nicht auf die andere Sache zugreifen, auf
den anderen Rechner zugreifen, what the fuck, ist das irgendwie, ist das irgendwie broken
oder so, was hat der für Schmerzen, Alter, ich will einfach nur meine Maus auf dem zweiten
Rechner verwenden können, auf dem zweiten Rechner punktieren sie ohne Probleme, ETF,
was ist das schon, eine Güte, ich hab keinen Bock zwei Maus zu verwenden, ok, läuft das
noch irgendwo, ah, guck mal, da läufts noch, ist noch an, end, ja, endtask, hallo, what
the fuck, who knows, please, lass mich zeug beenden, alter, ja, ich hab zwei PCs mit einer
Maus, das ist normalerweise überhaupt kein Problem, das ist jetzt seit, seit ich streame
das erste Mal, dass es nicht mag, ok, das läuft, aber es läuft doch nicht, guck mal,
ich kann dir sagen, Endtask, ich hab noch ne Idee, wir machen jetzt Trickstip, wir machen
jetzt den Prozess Explorer, der ist besser, als Admin, so, Maus, da ist es, zack, exe,
headchamp, ich bin Admin, ich darf das, restart, yes, what the fuck, was ist das für ne Scheiße,
ok, ist das irgendein Service, der läuft, I'm in, Hacker man, ok, ok, äh, Moment, das
muss man auch als Admin starten, Windows, das kann doch nicht sein, warum hat das immer
so komische Dinger zwischendurch, ok, mousewithoutborders, ist, start Service, ok, und jetzt, ey, was
ist das denn für ein Kack, what the, what, alter was, es kann doch jetzt nicht sein, dass
ich für so nen Müll, dass ich für so nen Müll den Rechner neu starten soll, oder,
das ist doch jetzt nicht euer Ernst, das kann doch nicht euer Ernst sein Windows, dass ich,
dass ich irgendwie neu starten soll dafür, jetzt nicht ernsthaft, oder, vor allem, warum
kann ich den Scheiß nicht benden, das ist eben abgekackt, deswegen hat eben auch meine
Maus geleckt, ne, das hat keinen Bock, ok, was, Task Kill, ja, das, ey, das macht der,
das geht damit nicht, das macht der hier sonst, ja gut, äh, Leute, ich brauch meinen 2.
Rechner, sonst kann ich weder Chat managen, noch irgendwie sonst was machen, ich bin gleich
wieder da, 2-3 Minuten.